financial markets in Asia have mostly
studied out today after a week where the
corona virus outbreak triggered huge
losses around the world the number of
new cases reported by China has dropped
sharply but the epidemic is still
spreading rapidly in other countries the
total number of infections around the
world now exceeds eighty nine thousand
people more than three thousand have
died Indonesia and several other
countries are reporting their first
cases officials in Italy the worst-hit
country in Europe said the number of
people infected with the virus jumped by
50 percent to nearly 1,700
not a tourist in sight the canals of
Venice without its famous gondolas no
sound of fans cheering in Milan's
football stadium either across Italy
five major matches have been postponed
due to the corona virus as new
infections climb dramatically in
Europe's worst hit country the Italian
government is imposing more drastic
measures army checkpoints control
quarantine areas in some regions and
emergency aid has been promised to the
sector's hardest hit by the rapid spread
of the virus in France tourists line up
outside the world's most visited museum
the Louvre on Sunday in vain they were
not allowed in the building after the
museum staff voted to keep its doors
shut due to fears of contamination from
the flow of tourists unfortunately is
closed so I'm a bit disappointed the
French government has banned gatherings
of more than 5,000 people closing down
trade fairs and large sporting events
even though a half marathon in Paris was
officially called off hundreds of
runners defied the ban and ran the full
course I'd signed up to take part in the
marathon and since I had nothing to do
this morning I thought I might as well
go and run it was my goal and if I can
do it why not we have to stop all this
paranoia with what's happening we have
to keep things in perspective in recent
days the US Australia and Thailand have
reported the first deaths on their soil
but with more than 50 deaths Iran has
the world's highest toll outside of
China the epidemic is impacting
businesses and daily life and shaking
the country is already struggling
economy people are panicked a little and
the stress has led to a drop in sales
people have also become more hygiene
obsessed and buy less food from bakeries
restaurants and caterers
as markets around the globe take a hit
some countries are more vulnerable than
others let's talk about the economic
consequences now with gerhard offers
from DW business idea HUD that's where
we last week was pretty bad for the
global market how what's the picture
like today well it's it's a bit better
today
Asian markets have recovered also
European markets have opened slightly up
the footsies up 2 percent so but it was
a slaughter
last week 5 trillion US dollars have
been wiped off shares that's 5,000
billion US dollars it's quite
unbelievable and it's it's not gonna be
the end of it there's a study out it
says that if the this pandemic lasts
another six months which is quite quite
likely it will wipe 1.1 trillion dollars
of global GDP growth so it is pretty
serious even though there's a slight
recovery today okay so what are
governments and central banks doing to
offset these losses well they've just
only begun to put things into motion
that's not so much they can do because
it's mainly a supply chain issue that is
hitting the hitting world's trade at the
moment china is the world's workshop
there's hardly any big company that does
not manufacture something in China gets
parts from China
raw materials from China so that makes
it difficult one striking rather
striking example Jaguar Land Rover in
the UK the car maker has actually sent
employees by plane to China to
hand-carry parts back to Britain because
the supply chain is so disrupted and
what governments can do of course
Germany has said it will make money
available or Germany is a big surplus so
it is rich enough to do that to help the
economy Italy is slightly different they
have said they put 3.6 billion to the
side to have the Italian companies there
are affected but they Italy doesn't have
that much money anyway so it's slightly
different and central banks of course
can't do something they can make money
cheaper they can lower interest rates
but since it's a supply-side issue not a
demand side it
cheap money doesn't really help that
much so what do you see things going
from here well we're gonna see more
earthquakes if you will
economic earthquakes and while people
stop traveling the airline and airlines
are in trouble the oil price is dropping
because demand is is low so there's a
chain reaction that's that's going on
that we're gonna have to report on quite
a lot in the next couple of months I
think and you'll be taking a closer look
at that coming up on DW business right
after this show get hurt Alvers with us
thank you
well the European Union has been
presenting its response to the
coronavirus crisis and DW starey schultz
is following that story for us in
Brussels hi Terry good to see you there
has been a press conference what has
been announced the European Commission
very much wants to give the appearance
that while they're taking the corona
infections very seriously everything
that can be under control
is under control so European Commission
President Ursula von der Leyen was
flanked by five commissioners from the
economy from Home Affairs crisis
response transport and health and each
one of them spoke to their own
particular expertise but they said that
the response overall is being
coordinated under three main pillars and
one is medical one is mobility and one
is the economy now what it's important
to point out that each member state has
its own crisis response and each one of
them makes their own decisions so the
Commission is saying hey count us a
count on us for a certain amount of
coordination but we don't make the
decisions for member states they also
wanted to update the figures on
infections there are now 2,100 2,100
confirmed cases across 18 member states
and 38 deaths Terry what is at stake
here for the EU the economics
commissioner paolo gentiloni said that
the stakes are very high economically he
said that early expectations that there
would be a fast drop followed by a fast
recovery may have been too optimistic
because we certainly don't know that
we've seen the end of it yet that that
there's any
containment in sight yet be and of
course he spoke about the fact that when
China is suffering something like this
of course it impacts the European Union
and that's not the only place you have a
lot of very worried citizens and each
commissioner said in their own way don't
panic but you have a lot of travelers
who are either having their flights
canceled or cancelling the flights
themselves and there are a lot of
questions about what kind of
compensation might be might be available
and it looks like this is going to be
one of those sort of acts of God
situations where you're not going to get
compensation so there were a lot of
questions at this press conference that
went on almost an hour and there will be
many more questions to come but the main
message right now is don't panic we've
got our hand we've got control of of
everything that can be under control and
we're watching very carefully and there
is now a new website where people can
can get all of the up-to-date
information from the European Commission
correspondent teri Schultz reporting
there for us from Brussels teri good to
talk to you schools in Japan have shut
down to contain the spread of the corona
virus it's a precautionary measure
announced by Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a
last week the decision affects some
twelve point eight million students
across nearly 35,000 schools around the
country
the schools are meant to remain shut
until spring holidays that begin in late
March Japan has so far reported a little
more than two hundred cases of kovat 19
the disease caused by the new strain of
corona virus school's out for millions
of Japanese children but while the
youngsters get an extended holiday many
parents are faced with a logistical
nightmare they need to make alternative
childcare arrangements while the schools
are shut I think companies need to be
flexible in dealing with the situation
[Music]
though why not that I really didn't
think that the virus would in fact so
many people it's good to close the
schools but a lot of parents work today
they have to take some time off sorry
for them Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a
said the drastic measure was necessary
after meeting with the country's
coronavirus task force on Thursday there
are many efforts being made to stop the
spread of infection among children in
various regions and the next one or two
weeks are crucial the announcement took
local government and health officials by
surprise
they've been scrambling to come up with
guidelines to implement the closures and
some politicians have warned that the
risks posed by shutting schools also
need to be considered the mayor of Chiba
Toshihiko Kumagai tweeted what about
parents and occupations that support
society how will they manage society
could collapse but with opinion polls
showing public dissatisfaction with our
BAE's handling of the corona virus
outbreak it appears the Prime Minister
is betting on school closures as an
effective strategy to bring new
infections under control for more
joining me from Tokyo is journalist
Michael Penn Michael thanks for being
with us the first day of the school
shutdown how has it been it's been a
little chaotic the lots of companies and
lots of their children are are
scrambling to to try to deal with a
situation that was unforeseen until just
a couple of days ago obviously you know
for the kids you know they may or may
not be happy to be out of school but the
the parents who out many of them who
depended on their kids being at school
so that they could go to work many of
them are in considerable trouble because
they have
take time off from work or to figure out
how to do teleworking and this is not
just you know one or two people in the
office it's it's essentially everybody
who has kids so at all at the same time
so it's been a major adjustment and you
know they're still gonna need time to
figure out how it's gonna work has it
basically just been left to the parents
and to the other relatives of the
children to try and figure out this
shutdown is the government assisting in
any way essentially Prime Minister obey
just requested that all of the schools
closed down and not every school not
every Prefecture actually obeyed his
request there is for example shame on a
Prefecture in western Japan which
completely ignored the Prime Minister's
requests but and there are other schools
as well but yes essentially it's been
left to all the various school boards
and all the various local governments
and all the various companies and all
the various individual parents to figure
out how to adapt to this to this issue
that the government did not do any
particular preparation and the decision
was made even without the input of the
Education Ministry so yeah everybody was
kept flat-footed and they're just trying
to figure out figure out as they go
along and there has been a fair bit of
criticism hasn't there Michel about the
government's decision especially
considering that this is a government
and a prime minister that is facing fire
and criticism over the response to the
corona virus outbreak was this a
political move
in fact the Prime Minister himself has
pretty much admitted that in
parliamentary debate today he was
cornered by opposition parties who said
who are trying to find out how he made
this decision and the Prime Minister was
forced to admit that in fact that he
made the decision without consulting any
experts and so it was basically Prime
Minister Abhi's own political decision
to do this personal without even many of
his own staff members on board with it
and so you know the government
was being criticized for being too lacks
and its handling of for example the the
diamond princess issue and other parts
of the infection and now they kind of
swung from going from what might have
been two lakhs to two possibly too harsh
and the government is in particular
crisis right now a kind of political
crisis which the Abba administration has
not seen in its seven years in power my
clip and joining us from Tokyo thank you
very much for that thank you